es ist immer so praktisch man surft
durchs internet ein klick und schon sind
waren bestellt da hofft man natürlich
dass die ware auch ankommt weil das geld
hat man natürlich schon über kreditkarte
oder über paypal bezahlt manchmal geht
das allerdings schief wir haben den fall
von wolfgang alessio und erzählt uns was
er erlebt hat
ich hatte bei einer auktion mit geboten
bei ebay die habe ich nicht gewonnen und
dann wurde ist trotz alledem vom
angeblichen besitzer angeschrieben ob
ich interesse hätte ich hatte auf zwei
standlautsprecher mitgeboten laufe
dieser konversation habe ich dann dieses
geld per paypal an waren und
dienstleistung gesendet wegen des
käufers dann bekam ich auf einmal eine
mail
bei ebay von dem tatsächlichen account
besitzer dass sein account gehackt wurde
hab dann sofort einen konflikt
lösungsfeld draus gemacht
der konflikt wurde geschlossen zu meinen
gunsten
in folge dessen dass der verkäufer einen
sendungs beleg wo es paket angeblich
zugestellt worden hatte eingereicht und
das ist alles was die wohl brauchen
sprich die 1300 euro wären dann jetzt im
endeffekt weg gewesen ja und deswegen
wollte ich sie im endeffekt um hilfe
bitten das ist da spricht mein geld
wieder zurückbekommen
ja herr alassio wir sind natürlich auch
sofort aktiv geworden
paypal hat uns zugesichert der fall wird
jetzt nochmal aufgerollt jetzt ist
relativ kompliziert weil wir haben es
gehört es geht hier um verschiedene
sendungen aber ich glaube wir sind guter
dinge dass das auch klappt an kempkens
ist das ein ganz typischer fall oder
anders gefragt was taugt so ein
virtueller käuferschutz überhaupt na ja
es funktioniert eigentlich ganz gut wir
haben ganz gute erfahrungen gemacht mit
diesem käuferschutz bei paypal dabei ja
die möglichkeit wenn die ware beschädigt
oder eben gar nicht ankommen dass man da
sein geld zurückbekommt das muss man
sich im einzelnen an
es gibt auch ausschlusstatbestände das
gilt beispielsweise nicht für selbst
abgeholte war also nur für versendung
käufe und dann gibt es natürlich
schwierigkeiten wie wir es gerade gehört
haben so mit gehackten kontos mit
gehackten internetkonten und/oder mit
auch natürlich mit ebay konten da ist
auf einmal jemand anders dahinter das
ist also betrugs sachverhalte die
eigentliche paypal diese käuferschutz
bezieht sich eher so ein bisschen auf
diese beschädigung bereich aber dieser
betrugs bereich da sollte man immer
unbedingt sofort anzeige erstatten da
ist oft das geld weg und da muss man als
inhaber eines kontos immer so ein
bisschen gucken läuft da vielleicht
irgendwas schief denn wenn der krumme
sachen über eigene konten abgewickelt
werden und man merkt das nicht dann kann
man dafür sogar haften das heißt man
sollte unbedingt immer seine eigenen
konten im auge behalten und sobald es da
schwierigkeiten gibt kontosperren und
aufkäufer sicht sollte man natürlich
sofort alle möglichkeiten nicht nur eine
sondern alle möglichkeiten sofort nutzen
käuferschutz an den verkäufer wenden und
gegebenenfalls auch an den polizei und
ganz wichtiger tipp von mir noch
tatsächlich wenn sich ein geschäft über
ebay anbahnt dann nicht darauf eingehen
wenn der verkäufer plötzlich sagt lass
uns mal per whatsapp chatten und wir
wickeln das geschäft mal eben schnell
außerhalb von ebay ab da ist natürlich
betrug tür und tor geöffnet wir fasten
auch diesen fall noch mal zusammen ganz
wichtig strafanzeige erstatten das ist
klar dann kann man auch beweisen dass es
hier tatsächlich auch um betrug geht
account besitzer haben es immer
schwierig wenn ja der eigene account
gehackt wird also tatsächlich der
account besitzer haftet da grundsätzlich
nicht nämlich nur dann wenn er
verschuldet sein
ein hacker das leicht gemacht hat und
ganz wichtig tatsächlich wirklich
bleiben sie dran und versuchen sie
wirklich diesem fall vielleicht auch
sogar gütlich zu klären am ende kann man
natürlich immer noch vielleicht vor
gericht gehen aber es ist immer ganz
ganz schwierig es ist kompliziert und
tatsächlich möchte ich das wirklich kaum
wünschen dass ihm so etwas passiert